yeah that's like the number one thing
you could do to have a lot of success
with a new platform is
go back in time 14 years so the thing
you have to kind of think about is
what is the like what's the totally new
thing
that uh ten years from now it would seem
obvious
i mean some people are saying clubhouse
is that there's been a lot of stuff
like clubhouse before yeah but it
it hit the right kind of thing uh
similar to tesla actually
what clubhouse did is it got a lot of
relatively famous people on there
quickly
and um and then the the other effect is
like
it's invite only so like oh all the
smart like famous people are on there i
wonder what's
it's the fomo like fear that you're
missing something really profound
there's
exciting happening there so those social
effects
and then once you actually show up i'm a
huge fan of this
it's the javascript model it's like
clubhouse is
so dumb like so simple in this interface
like you literally can't do anything
except mute on mute
there's a mute button yeah and there's a
leave quietly button yeah that's it
yeah and it's it's kind of i love
single-use technology
yeah that that sense yeah there's no
like there's no it's just like
trivial and uh you know twitter kind of
started like that
facebook started like that yeah but
they've evolved quickly to add all these
features and so on
and you know i do hope clubhouse stays
that way yeah
be interesting or there's alternatives i
mean i mean even with clubhouse though
so one of the issues with a lot of these
platforms i think is uh
bits are cheap enough now that
we don't really need a unicorn investor
model i mean the investors need that
model
there's really not really an imperative
of we need something that can scale
to 100 million plus a year revenue so
because it's going to require this much
seed and angel investment and and you're
not going to get this much seed angel
investment unless you can have a
potential exit this this wide because
you have to be part of a portfolio that
depends on one out of ten
exiting here if you don't actually need
that
and you don't need to satisfy that
investor model which i think is
basically the case i mean bits are so
cheap everything is so cheap
you don't necess so even like with
clubhouse it it's investor backed right
this notion of like this needs to be
a major platform um but the bike club
doesn't necessarily need a major
platform that's where i'm interested i
mean i don't know
there's so much money that's the only
problem that bets against me is that
you can concentrate a lot of capital if
you do these things right yeah i mean so
facebook was like a
fantastic capital concentration machine
it's crazy how much
where it even found that capital in the
world that it could concentrate and
ossify in the stock price that a very
small number of people have
you know access to right that's that's
incredibly powerful
so when they're when there is a
possibility to to to consolidate and
gather a huge amount of capital that's a
huge imperative that's very hard for the
bike club to go up against so
but there's a lot of money in the bike
club you see with the wall street
uh bets yeah and then when a bunch of
people
get together i mean it doesn't have to
be a bike it could be a bunch of
different bike clubs
just kind of team up yeah and to
overtake
that's what we're doing now yeah yeah or
we're gonna repurpose off-the-shelf
stuff yes
that's not scale you were gonna yeah
we're gonna repurpose whatever it was
for office productivity or something and
like the the club's using slack just to
build out these you know
you